[Music]
let's go to eddie in austin texas what's
up eddie
uh yes hi hi doctor thank you for taking
my call of course brother how are you
man well
well not well i'm not a man of many
words but
right now this is a tough one for for me
my wife my family my 21 year old son
about a month ago suffered a
mental breakdown
and uh
so um
quickly i i uh
i found out that this mental health
system is it's really it's really
difficult to navigate um yes to help my
son it's a mess
yeah like hold on hold on a second eddie
um
number one i'm gonna stop right there
thank you for calling
it's a hard call to make
okay so um the the number of dads i've
sat with in your exact seat i can't
count them there's been a lot and i know
this is a hard hard moment to say it out
loud and i want to just want to applaud
your bravery okay it's hard
very very hard
uh when you say your son had a mental
breakdown what does that mean what
happened
well we found out he had been a
he was on his own uh living in san
antonio okay
he was he had a steady income job
became a realtor
he left that steady income job
to go 100
commission
it was hard he he was he's a he's a
young guy man that he's a hard worker
he he
he has no dad he invests his money
and all of a sudden he oh well
he uh
he just started
having problems with
with his memory
had he started
getting really paranoid about things
yeah
he seemed to lose touch of
reality at times
and uh found out that he had a month
this happened about about a month ago
found out that before that a month
before that he had quit smoking
marijuana he was a daily user
and uh
also a cbd
user which
i didn't know what that was until now
and uh
so that that that's what happened so he
couldn't function he he
we brought him home with us
and we you know we were if i if i break
my ankle doctor i go to the er and i get
it fixed i get a cast on if i break
something in my brain
[Applause]
no one no one seems to know how to
how to help you help
i know it's not that easy it's
complicated but it's complicated but it
it is that easy and it is that
complicated so it's both and okay and
the the challenge here is to not lean
into the despair part
okay
and at the same time
you gotta lean into the grief part and
we'll get to that but real quick
often
um by the way i have zero none
um i've no issues with with cbd i
haven't seen any sort of studies
whatsoever that suggests that's in that
that has any sort of
negative effects on somebody okay it is
a hemp derivative but i that doesn't
bother me
it it i would say
my students used to and and friends kids
especially would go i would always tell
people don't buy health products at a
gas station that's never the place to
get that stuff right um but that didn't
bother me
my question for you about the hemp i
mean about cbd about marijuana often
when people feel themselves starting to
slowly unspool
that helps or that's where they go they
end up there they might drink they might
they starting to look for ways to tamp
down
an increasingly
loud volatile brain
and also i've heard recently in the past
few years people
just smoke and weed with their buddies
and it's got fentanyl in it and they
literally cook their brain and so my
question for you is
is
any sort of his doctor any doctor said
this is a a
chemical induced issue or
actually the marijuana was your son
trying to self-medicate a
um a pretty quickly devolving
psychological state
well he he was he was uh smoking
marijuana so that he can calm down
okay he had he had a he had a lot of
stress and he said you know he would
he would use it to go to sleep and to
function and focus okay all right um i i
did i did take him recently to a mental
clinic uh that is um
tied to
ut health center okay and um nurse
practitioner under a
psychiatrist
has diagnosed him with substance induced
psychosis okay
and general and and general anxiety
disorder okay
um other other places
uh
they diagnosed him with severe
depression
but again
in some places since he's 21
they don't let the you know the parents
go in and yeah
they don't see the other things that
happen they only hear what he he tells
them right
sometimes you know that's not the full
picture gotcha okay
so
do me a favor and take a huge deep
breath
and hold it
okay as deep as your lungs can hold
and let it out
all right okay
so if you have um substance abuse
induced psychosis
or extreme anxiety to the point that
um
your body's rattling
or you have um severe depression
i can
i can see a place where these are all on
some sort of similar trend line let me
give you some peace of mind that they
didn't both come back and say your son's
got something like schizophrenia
okay
though you're talking about two very
different paths
forward okay
and so
um
i'm not saying this to belittle my
friends and community members who've got
family members with schizophrenia what
i'm saying is if i took my son in i
would much rather a diagnostic out of
the gate of he smoked so much weed he
right he rattled his body up okay
or he's so anxious he took a job and he
put himself in a situation where his
body said hey i'm out or he's been
pushing and pushing and pushing and
pushing and pushing
and he's got some childhood traumas et
cetera and he's ended up very very
depressed
i would much rather walk that road with
my son
than
get a diagnosis of schizophrenia
okay like a a psychiatric illness due to
brain lesions or brain functioning does
that make sense
yeah it does okay so i'm trying to give
you a light here okay
thank you yeah
um
can i can i ask you something
you can ask me anything you want to you
got it um
should i keep should i keep um you know
i i quickly found out that there's other
mental health clinics that i can take
him
cost a lot of money would cost us a lot
of our life savings to take him
um should i should i go that route to
get the the right diagnosis if to be
sure and you know
so that i can
you know move forward with this i don't
know what
right now
what when you went to the the ut system
and you met with the the
psychiatrist or the the psychiatric
nurse practitioner did they give you a
plan of of action moving forward
or do they just write you a script and
send you out the door they
they they do they they gave me they gave
him uh you know the prescription
medicine to take as needed um he does
follow up he's gonna follow up with a
therapist okay
um
he he is much better
than he was with when this crisis event
happened to him you know he's doing a
little bit better he he wants he lives
in san antonio and we have actually a
family property there and he's been
staying there okay
by himself i don't know that's healthy
for him
um
you know he's not working i'm helping
him uh
at um
you know
that's another issue that you know that
that where my wife and i have been
confident
knowing you know
how to how to move forward with it
so let me tell you what i would do in
your situation okay
number one um
what the
psychiatrist gave you the the
psychiatric mp gave you
is a very standard treatment of care
okay
okay they gave him some medicine to and
the fact that she said as needed
would give me another level of relief
that sounds like and again i'm not there
so i'm speaking off the cuff here okay
but it sounds episodic
meaning this is not indicative of if you
keep pressing the same way we were
pressing yes eventually we're gonna have
some the if we keep driving the car the
way we were driving it eventually this
engine's gonna stop right
but yeah what she's saying is
hey take this gas treatment as if you
hear knocks and pings
and you got to drive safer and by the
way we're going to
um we're going to do some things to help
along the way so that's number one the
next thing would be is you need to get
some new driving lessons okay
and
the what the data tells me is
research is very clear that
therapy plus the medication is the magic
there okay
and i've got my own opinions on that
they're not important right now
i think getting your son
um in with a good therapist right now is
really really important
and so if i'm gonna i've spent money
somewhere and again this is just me
talking if i'm gonna spend money in my
life somewhere i'm not gonna go chase a
third and a fourth and a fifth diagnosis
i'm just not
i'm gonna get off of youtube
okay right i'm gonna go get with a
good
counselor and lucky luckily you're in an
area you're in that area between austin
and san antonio do there's some great
practitioners there
okay of all different flavors and here's
what the the scholarship tells us
doesn't matter the flavor as much as it
matters the relationship between the
therapist and the client okay
correct what does that mean find a place
where your son feels comfortable where
he can go tell the truth
okay
that's going to be more important than
is it an mft or a psychologist or say
the psychiatrist does the medical stuff
um
i want you to go find help him find a
good counselor okay
now here's really important
if i'm you
and he's willing to
do the work to get well
i would probably ask my son i give him
the option to come live with me for six
months and get things lined back up
um i am a person who believes that um
loneliness and isolation is one of the
chief drivers of anxiety
okay and so that idea that i'm on my own
i'm on my own i'm on my own our bodies
are simply not designed to exist that
way they're just not um and this is
thousands of years old we're just not
wired to live that way
and
um so i would give him the option and
that option would come with some
stipulations you got you can't miss
counseling
um
we're gonna help out x and we're gonna
help out with why but you got to get a
job you got to have some sort of purpose
you got to have some reason for to get
up and go
which is the little wins which helps in
both depression and it helps in in
anxiety okay
and
we're going to have some
weekly check-ins just dad and son going
to breakfast
talking about talking about the astros
right i mean we're going to do some
we're going to re-do human stuff
not about the diagnosis and how you're
feeling and give me a 1-10 scale that's
for him and the counselor we're going to
start doing life
you get what i'm saying
yeah
really yeah
um and so that i mean that's if i'm in
your exact situation that's that's the
path i would take and he could he's 21
he could tell me to screw off he could
tell me i'm not coming home
um he could tell me no i'm gonna keep
i'm gonna keep hammering away at this
job i'm gonna keep doing it he's 21 he
can do that the other thing you can do
here is also
um he doesn't have to do this
but you can ask for a release from a
psychiatrist or his counselor and if
you're paying for it that might be part
of it unless he's not going to go
the other thing is you can always give
information one way to a
counselor and every therapist i know
really welcomes that information
meaning if he gets a therapist or
psychiatrist or something you can send
them an email of hey he was abused as a
child him and his my
me and his his mom gotten fights and
like whatever the history you think you
need that that therapist needs to know
you're welcome to send that
sure okay he didn't find the release
okay great
yes so i do have that access to that and
what what about when he it
he's you know he is taking medicine as
needed and but he does want to take that
cbd is that
okay or is that
that's between him and his doctor quite
honestly um
i know people that were highly anxious
and
i can only attribute it to cbd helping
reset the
uh
anxiety response
there's a whole chemical pathway there
um and then i've i've talked to
practitioners who say dude we see little
to no
help
okay
uh it makes it worse though
i've not seen that i've never seen that
again that's a question for him
outside of it yeah i've never seen any
sort of data or any sort of personal
experience or any sort of
um if it helps you i take i take cbd i
take a clinical grade um i used to take
it quite regularly when i was struggling
with anxiety and now i take it very
sparingly okay i've never seen any sort
of connectivity between
cbd and psychosis
maybe if you took a ton of it or
something um i also don't smoke um
so i'm not gonna smoke anything either
and by the way i get it from a
highly reputable clinical great company
i don't get it from a gas station
okay okay so that's just my per that's
just my personal thing what i would
strongly recommend though is have that
conversation with the psychiatric mp
and if he or she says no then absolutely
cut it off because everybody's different
and he made him need a time to reset his
reset himself
okay okay but you have some have some
peace there
um thank you
is there some things in his history in
his past that you're worried about
or is this just a matter of a young kid
getting out on the zone and trying to
hit the gas too hard and then got to
smoking a lot a lot a lot not sleeping
very much and living off red bull and
monster energy drinks and all of a
sudden just spun out i i i think i think
he had some stressors that i just you
know that came about um that have that
contributed to this
um
where he used to work
he had a he was a property manager of
you know a real estate company
and he had to he
he got a call that he had to go to some
apartment complex or whatever to ask him
what to to move their car because they
were parked in the right spot
got a gun pulled up on him
um
is
another thing that he found out was
recently his
girlfriend had an abortion he's pro-life
okay so he's dealing with a lot of
trauma
trauma
yeah
i asked him what
he's like just being on his own was hard
for him and he he's not one to ask for
help i said why why don't you ever come
to me and ask for help i mean his truck
broke down and so i think
a lot of things just bottled up and so
hey
let me give you a a tool okay
um yeah
often when somebody's hurting
or when somebody's being abused or when
somebody any kind of thing like that
we go to them and our first thought is
dude why didn't you tell me i would have
stood arm-in-arm with you i would have
thrown the first punch why didn't you
tell them to say anything
right here's the here's the response
i've seen in my own life and in those i
walk with and work with in their life
that has become more a more effective
entry point into that conversation
especially between fathers and sons
son i'm sorry that i didn't give you a
picture of what asking for help looks
like
either you're a person who asks for help
a lot
and your son never saw that
or
you model those same things
and you're a good texan who just figures
it out
and when you don't figure it out you
crack another beer and then you figure
it out the next day right and
what i have found is asking somebody why
didn't you simply adds to the list of
things
that they it fee their body responds as
it's a fracture in our relationship
which is going to sound those alarms
even louder the entry point being dude
i'm so sorry i didn't give you a picture
of what this looks like that's on me
here's my commitment moving forward
will you make that commitment with me
that's that's that's a much different
entry point because that's saying we're
going to do this together not why didn't
you screw this up
or why did you screw this up
and just for the the dad's listening out
there the other day i was
driving with my son and i was having a
relatively hard conversation
in the conversation was being had with
me
with a
the number one he's one of the top
researchers in the planet in his
particular thing i'm struggling with a
i'm trying to get something worked out
with my physiology with my diet and it's
not working the way i wanted it to work
and it's frustrating for me
and i was talking to on the phone and my
son was just sitting there
and i thought you know what he needs to
hear
another expert telling his dad
that his dad's
ways to try to hack the system are not
working and he needs to just follow the
plan so i put on speakerphone
and this guy's great human being funny
and also has given it to me a little
give me the like hey you got to do this
right but i wanted my son to hear that
and then afterwards i said hey
i know you know this but i call people
to help with coaching too because i need
to get help too
and he's like i know dad i know and i
said no no i need you to hear that i was
talking to the number one person in the
country on this topic
and i still was acting as though i was
smarter than him and this is him setting
me straight as as a friend
and so i let him listen to that because
i want him to have a picture of what
asking for help looks like as he gets
older okay but
i would start that way with my son eddie
okay
thank you um i would trust that the
system that you've mentioned is good
they've got a great reputation i would
trust that um the nurse practitioner i
would trust the
path she gave you forward or he gave you
forward i would get a counselor or psych
a psychologist in your area
and i would ask give my son permission
to come home for six months come on for
nine months and here's the thing it's
helpful for everybody to put a time
limit on that
you don't have to stick to the time
limit
but if you ask a 21 year old why don't
you come on home
you can look up and it's three years and
you don't like each other anymore and
there's a whole mess or it could feel
like dude i'm gonna fail your no no
we're just coming on for six months come
on for six months and let's see if we
can get this thing dialed in i'll start
having breakfast with my son and
i need to have some healing too and so
let's start doing this together and then
we'll reevaluate in five and a half
months and we'll see what comes next it
might be another six months after that
maybe that's it right enough to get him
on get his feet underneath him
and he's got to deal with the trauma the
loss
he's gonna have to deal with the fear of
getting a gun pulled on he's got to deal
with all that stuff and that's what a
counselor is gonna help him walk through
and based on the limited stuff you told
me it sounds like his body had enough
there was no margin because the way he
was living there's no margin here no
margin there no margin no margin no
margin and then somebody pulled a gun on
him
and then his girlfriend violated a core
value of his right and and really hurt
him deeply and and we could go on and on
and on
all i have to say is
your son's not broken
he's not dysfunctional and he's not lost
this is a great time to hit control
delete on your relationship with your
son your wife's relationship with her
son and to say hey let's lean into
connectivity into relationship
let's follow what the doctors say and
let's be about healing and as someone
who has struggled mightily with anxiety
i want you to know on the other side of
it there's light and there's a lot of
laughter and there's a lot of joy
and
there's good stuff it's worth it's worth
the effort thank you so much for your
bravery and for being vulnerable eddie
i'm grateful for you